[Music]
hey
welcome to honest trailers commentaries
you know the show by now we watch the
other show and we talk about movies um
there's joe there's lon if you stick
around there's deleted scenes we'll talk
about your comments if you got them
and we will uh tease next week's on this
trailer which should also be
another good one um i don't have a
script in front of me ryan is there
anything i'm supposed to plug
no no we are we're we're all good sorry
hug free baby unchained
yeah born fresh whatever we want you get
to promote
one brand of your choice throughout the
songstream
i will be uh um shilling for the ford
f-150
built ford tough thanks guys no plugs
for me and my brother dozer
uh and let's see let's see that's like
skittles they're good
have some skittles are nice i like them
we've got a christmas story this week
um which was a a film that
you know i wonder how much we pulled our
punches because
um we know this is so beloved because i
don't think any of us really love a
christmas story
and like you know correct me if i'm
wrong we can go around
i always kind of thought it was like a
jew thing that i i didn't love this
movie
because i didn't have that kind of
christmas growing up like
we it wasn't like i was denied christmas
like you gotta pray you know we weren't
like a very strict religious hospital
but i also didn't have like
a family that had beloved christmas
traditions and really made a big thing
out of it
because um you know not not our not our
bag
not our folk so right so i always assume
that just growing up
that way meant that this movie didn't
mean as much to me obviously i saw it as
a kid a bunch of times but i just
figured that was why it didn't mean as
much to me but now that i've grown up to
be an adult
i found that a lot of other people jew
and gentile alike
all kind of feel that way that it's like
you're you're kind of
we all kind of have this movie in our
collective
mental library more than like we all
love it
if it's if it's regional though because
you know between
us danielle john kevin like
we have no one from the midwest i think
we have no midwesterners and this could
be like uh
like a stocky cheese filled midwestern
uh
is it that great of a movie if you have
to be from indiana to appreciate it
well it's like you have to be from
california to like unironically like
sublime
you know it's one of those things how
dare you yeah i disagree i think a
christmas story makes midwesterners of
all of us
uh i i think this movie
is beyond being good or bad or liked
and it just is um a christmas story
is as much a part of you as is going
home for the holidays
and having to hear the same story about
that one time in high school that your
dad tells
every year that you go home and then you
watch a christmas story and then
some relative gives you that little sack
of gold foil chocolate coins
in the little net you know those uh
guilt
you're describing hanukkah guilt that's
ours you can't have that one yeah don't
appropriate our our
crappy chocolate wrapped yeah that's our
choice
chocolate that ends up tasting like the
foil i'm appropriating your jewish stuff
[Laughter]
yeah i just i don't i don't have a real
or a comedy writer free
but yeah
i do own a bank um
yeah i don't it's a christmas story man
i watch it every
year i don't know if you can have
christmas without it
yeah i don't know what it would be even
like to
encounter this with fresh eyes like this
most recent time
watching i noted how the narration he
kind of like
it's kind of the same beat over and over
again where he's just like
investing this dumb childhood thing with
so much
extra significance and weight like i
couldn't believe
my eyes i was seeing it it was really
there
a present for me you know and it's just
like i never even noticed that
beat before it's just like you this
movie just washes over you
i think also well it has a certain
timeless quality because we've seen it
every year
for for our entire lives but it also is
kind of just
it's so of its time and i feel like this
movie
i hate to say it but like i think this
would be
a prime candidate to just like do a
remake set in the 80s like to ready
player won this and be like i really
wanted an
n64 or like a paintball gun or something
like that
i really think that like you could
totally
make it better with like a few if you
remade this a few decades later like the
30s are just
such a far removed from me growing up i
don't know
i don't know in 1992 we got in the
biggest pickle to get a super scope
six i mean yeah like that's the
trade-off is you'd be
it would be a lot more relevant but you
would lose that like
rose-colored glasses nostalgia like oh
you think people aren't
looking at rose-colored glasses back on
the 90s like
come on i guess but part of the opinion
i think of a christmas story is that
it's so removed from our time it's like
this dream
of what the past used to be yeah
no and i think you couldn't get that for
the 80s because we remember it a
christmas story is that weird like
blanket when you go to your grandparents
house and that's the only blanket
and like it makes you sneeze but you're
also cold
and but that's the only blanket and
christmas story is the only blanket
uh i think it speaks to
how brilliant how well how timeless but
also how brilliant that the tnt plan to
just play it for 24 hours every
christmas is
because you know every inch of this
movie so you can
turn it on like at any point and just be
like oh let's watch the rabbit thing
real quick and watch like four minutes
of a christmas story
but chances are they'll get you for at
least like 10 minutes because you're
like oh here comes soap
and like we comment on this in the
trailer like the fact that it's so
episodic really plays into this too that
it is not really a big like
through line movie like you get the he
wants the bb gun
but it's mostly and then this is the
thing that happened with my dad and then
this thing happened with the mall and
it's a good movie to like tune into and
tune out of
like on a 24-hour loop a series of
shorts all set
in the same world but i do think like
that also is the explanation for a big
amount of its popularity i think if you
played i don't know
mixed nuts on the loop on tps
or whatever we'd all be quoting mixed
nuts over here
it does feature a delightful early
sandler performance let's here we go
um all right let's watch uh honest
trailer for a christmas story we'll have
more to say as we go along
here it was we were finally doing a
christmas story
oh joy
wait is this movie even good or do we
just like it because we have the whole
thing memorized
a christmas story this holiday season
when everyone in your family starts
yelling at each other put on a christmas
story
and enter the warm confines of a
nostalgia turducken
in a film that looks back fondly on the
childhood the narrator looks back fondly
on
that makes you look back fondly on
watching it as a kid and return to the
american midwest in the broke-ass 30s
where listening to the radio is
considered um
i saw uh um the rarest of birds
uh an interesting comment posted on this
video uh which was that
um this film actually judging by like
the broadcast of the little orphanage uh
which was i guess a real radio episode
that this takes place in 1940
and that um um the uh supposition was
that perhaps
this was the happiest christmas of his
life because the next christmas would
have been world war ii
and that was like after that you know he
became a man and like
he was coming to germany ralphie got his
gun
enlisted he lied about his age yeah
they made that sequel about the summer
but this is what it should have been
just uh on the beach at normandy
having private rally yeah a d-day story
yeah um cool well there you go uh some
food for thought
we discussed this sort of the little
behind the scenes because i believe the
gene
shepherd's stories are about his
childhood in the 20s
so like they fudged some of the era
purposefully here to like move it
forward
i don't know why too many too many
flappers in the original
yeah no one would understand if they
used studebakers instead of oldsmobiles
like that right so
so it's it's not exactly when he would
have actually
been a child experiencing this kind of
christmas it's like
pushed a little a little forward they
didn't have bb guns in the west egg
1930 i tell you this is also just russia
right fodder for uh um you know people
who
say that they don't make original ideas
anywhere because this is all this is an
adaptation
of radio stories that got adapted into a
short story collection that got adapted
into a film
so yeah there's been one original idea
the bible okay keep going
30s we're listening to the radio is
considered fun
you could still smack a kid around for
laughs
and all the toys sucked the real great
depression
trying to have fun with a wagon full of
raggedy hands hey while i have you here
anyone want to sell me their ps5
meet ralphie back before he got hot an
executive produced iron man
follow along on a single-minded quest to
acquire a firearm
and fight against america's only form of
gun control
parents no shoot your eye out as this
little boy spends the entire film
scheming for a gun
i want an official red rider carbon
action 200 range while
dreaming about a gun and making up
outlandish threats to justify owning a
gun
but if you do come back you'll be
pushing up daisies
is that what it feels like to be a
republican
i love him i think that his fantasy
sequences are my favorite
part of the movie um mostly for his
costume choices
like he's dressed like a like a
rhinestone cowboy
and uh yeah when he um he does the like
orphanage thing
uh or whatever that fantasy sequence is
in so
like yeah i think that this movie is
best when it does
like flights of fancy and stuff because
there is
no plot otherwise yeah i mean the whole
movie is just kind of like
take take this recognizable scenario and
then like
wouldn't it be funny to view this from
the perspective of this
boy you know like he doesn't doesn't
always understand everything that's
happening against these kind of
juvenile ideas and so the fantasy
sequences really play into that
like now we're totally just getting his
perspective
uh instead of you know like the old man
like reminiscing about here's how i felt
when i was 10 or whatever
i mean to me like soap poisoning that is
like legitimately
cute and funny when the when he has that
whole thing about see i think that's
another thing about if this were
to if this were in the 80s and it felt
more
relevant people would get upset by stuff
that's so out of time like that like
that's child abuse
whereas it's safe because it's in the
30s it's like ah that was like your
grandpa
it was like a different time you know
like we can we can enjoy the comedy of
it without being concerned about in my
80s remake you don't have to
keep you don't have to keep the child
abuse in my 80s remake you're not going
to like oh you'd be
hitting the kid with like a duck hunt
gun like or something
i don't know name another washington's
about that was so it's just uh that you
know like
pump action uh you know hand soap from
your sink
yeah exactly they didn't happen in the
30s yeah even that's worse somehow
it is yeah chugging that that is one way
to stop coronavirus
um don't fact man fact-check listen
don't inject bleach and don't eat
pants so from your sink keep going
gather round for a film that isn't
really about family or generosity
or christmas but more about crafts
materialism
survival and the universal holiday
message of
stop snitching you ready to tell me
ralph do you know where flick is
there is a family in it though and boy
is this one hanging by a thread
dad's got rage issues
mom's on the verge of a nervous
breakdown my mother had not had a hot
meal for herself
in 15 years and the little brother is a
ball of anxiety and eating disorders
held together my parkas
tell mommy how the piggies eat i can't
put my arms out
you just know they're about to shatter
faster than an
accidentally broken leg lamp
you use a clue
well first of all she definitely broke
that on purpose but yes was eight or
else disturbed by the
seemingly massive age difference between
the two of them
he's like an old man maybe you just like
lived harder in the 30s but
i mean hollywood has still never
recovered from the like
the male actor is 40 or 50.
and his female lead is
26 like all of tom cruise's
romantic interests are still like 20
years younger than him they've never
yeah but look
tom you know not not excusing the
practice in principle but
tom cruise is an ageless looking man
whereas that looks like
grandpa and let's look at that old man
yeah i mean his name in the script is
the old man yeah i mean darren mcgavin
was
like he had been cold shack the night
stalker already like a decade before
this even came out like he was got to be
pushing 60 by this point well
it's the same with like king of queens
and sitcoms and stuff you have the old
schlub
and their and their hot wife and it just
it just is
it just is uh i will say though
yeah they are they are uh they are about
about
16 years apart uh darren mcgavin was
born in 22
melinda dillon was born in 39 so there
you go spence
wow she's aging out man she's getting
replaced with a lamp
especially just i don't know this scene
and watching a few of his
highlights i i think the big reason this
sticks around
is they're all working overtime man
everyone in this movie is legitimately
great um
just re-watching like the performances
and stuff like that it's almost like a
disservice
in a way to be like it's popular because
it's been here forever like everyone
is really funny in this he's the dad's
amazing
uh he's in like the funniest comedic
stage play of all time in this movie
uh not a finger and bumpuses and you
know all that stuff
everybody's just firing all cylinders i
think is one of the reasons why it
continues to hold up
it is good child actor performances i do
like peter billingsley and and
i think i think ralphie's funny uh
ralphie's funny ralph is legitimately
funny he annoys
some people um not me i think that that
lying there when he like plays dead is a
is a great
it's a great beat yeah um sure all right
i'll grant you good performances
um no i mean listen i don't think any of
us are saying it's
it's a terrible movie it's just it is
what it is it's kind of hokey
it's got a very kind of sitcom
sensibility and i think that in the era
when it came out there were a lot of
film comedies that still had that
sensibility today it feels a little
a little throwback but you know i don't
think it's a terrible movie i just think
it's like
it's an okay movie that somehow has
inserted itself into all of our lives
forcibly and there's no going back well
i think that's why you hit the nail on
the head though because it's that
throwback feel is why it's
that weird norman rockwell christmas
feeling where like so much of christmas
itself feels like a throwback sometimes
you know it's like but weirdly it
doesn't have the throwback
morality of like a norman rockwell
americana thing like
it is really just about getting the toy
you want
and then like your dad freaking out and
your your parents marriage falling apart
and then like
dogs steal your turkey it doesn't have
that like you know what's really
important
like the me the family and like the
meaning of christmas
it's about like ralphie's loss of
innocence if anything
it doesn't do the christmas vacation at
the end where like bring bring it all
back to the reason for the season
yeah i mean i've got to assume when this
came out people were like this is
subversive
it subverts expectations this is the
last jedi of christmas book you could
really use linus coming out on stage at
the end of just explaining to us in
plain language
while we celebrate yes hey guys i don't
know if you knew this but um
it's a wonderful life it's not the funny
romp that you remember
it's actually very dark you know he
almost kills himself in that movie
that's what it's about thank you
headline for clearing that out
all right let's keep going you
use up all the glue on
purpose bask in the warmth of gene
shepard's radio voice the greatest
christmas gift i had ever received or
would ever receive
as you revisit his favorite christmas
where he got attacked in the streets
had a mental breakdown ain't so got
betrayed by his favorite show
got kicked in the hand by santa finally
got what he wanted for christmas
and immediately shot himself in the face
with it oh my god i
shot my eye out dear lord if this is the
happiest time of his life i'd hate to
see what happened the other years did he
have to work in a coal mine
did krampus get him i like that we had
the coal mine uh clip ready to go from
radiance last week
so lon you've seen the or joe too have
you seen the sequel
there's there's a sequel to this movie
my my summer story
i believe yeah i have seen it but not
not recently
on hbo once when i was like
in high school i think we had like an
hbo trial and it was on
sounds bad and yeah it had to have been
right
it's about like a tops competition like
spinning tops that's what it's about
yeah wow it's uh charles grodin takes
over
the role of the dad i believe from uh
darren mcgavin in it and yeah
yeah it's like it's a little bit like
this where they all kind of have their
own
i think it's more like by family member
like dad has a story line mama has a
storyline ralphie has a storyline
um mom's hooked on laden
and it is it's it's like it's only i
think it's 41 so it's like the next year
but the summer
okay so still before before ralphie went
to war
the day which will live in infamy which
caused ralphie to immediately enlist
ralphie get your gun all right keep
going join me it's just
behind enemy lines in germany in the
rabbit suit
so whip up some ovaltine and enjoy a
movie that's like old cinematic
wallpaper
it's chipped and faded and we should
probably replace it
but they still play that scene on tv and
we'll never get around to trying
something new
cause sure you could watch elf if you
want to laugh out loud which also has
peter billingsley in it or throw on
netflix to see whatever random word the
algorithm decided to pair with christmas
but you know you'll just tune it to tnt
or tbs and watch a christmas story yet
again
stuck in the same loop is that one real
a trash truck christmas did we
[Music]
i wonder which ones kevin made up
himself some of them are definitely real
because i've seen some of those
i never paused this long enough to look
i thought i just assumed these were all
real
but a trash truck christmas car look it
up
i've seen uh um christmas chronicles
i've seen christmas prints
the night before bed mom's christmas is
real christmas i've seen operation
christmas drop on there
yeah christmas break-in it's real baby
no when santa crash lands in the
junkyard on christmas eve
hank trash truck and their animal
friends all have a hand in rescuing oh
okay there is there's a kid series on
netflix called
trash truck where it's a kid and his
best friend who is a trash truck
it's just they must be their christmas
special that is true
but uh why wouldn't that you would think
the thumbnail would be
colorful that looks like a true crime
documentary
it means it looks like this christmas
they found 12 bodies
yeah they found a torso in the junkyard
like the mystery of db cooper's trash
truck
weirdly even though he's a cartoon he
looks like a michael bay transformers
design
i don't know yeah he could be in
bumblebee for sure i like i i i suck
because i do the newsletter so i saw the
trailer for this and the opening is just
the kids like
my mom i'm gonna go play with trash
truck and she's like bye sweetie and
it's like that's negligent
like you don't trust your kid with a
sentient garbage truck
you don't know that truck she was
already clearly letting him play in the
dump
um so i mean not mama like it's a little
bit of like the back to the future like
how did this
child even befriend this garbage truck
how did they meet what were the
circumstances
well two days of trash truck origins i'm
sure you'll be watching it soon
it's gonna be gritty maybe that's one
sponsor for the it's trash yeah
next season will be a ford f-150 built
for tough
i need a new car guys come on let's
let's crowdfund this baby
never always for an f-150 all right keep
going
decided to pair with christmas but you
know you'll just tune it to tnt or tbs
and watch a christmas story yet again
stuck in the same loop of conflict and
catharsis you can never escape from
no matter how old you get huh i guess it
is a movie by family after all
starring fudged red
the player's ball
flagpole liquor i love lamb
i hate lamb billy bob thornton
and yellow eyes are a sign of liver
disease he should really get that
checked out
so pause good um as it happens fairly
often these days we'll be
recording the script for the honest
trailer and john will be like yo i'm
like good buddies with uh with scott
farkas
like of course you are so
yeah he just he just threw it out there
like yeah uh
i was he's like an indie filmmaker like
i did uh i did some stuff for him where
we go way back and uh bravo you know
he uh we thought he was just gonna read
the comments but then i think kevin had
the idea like
he could do like a back and forth and uh
and so it goes sometimes these things
come together at the last second
that's the story there you go that's how
scott farkas is in the christmas scott
park
sorry i'm looking up his name zach ward
his name is not scott farkas
he's an adult and he has a name so think
yellow eyes in real life
that's great much appreciated zack and
uh and thank you john for the hookup and
you can uh
check out zach's stuff he's on cameos
darth varkus
so get those uh get a good christmas
cameo for for your loved ones
link in the description of the honest
trailer if they want to link to i'll put
it in the i'll try to put it in the
commentary description
as well yeah now you too can be
viciously bullied
wouldn't want that yeah all right keep
going
[Laughter]
scud forecast how did you get in here i
heard you were slapping your soup
suckers together tucking some trash
about me
calling me some names that wasn't me
honest do you want atomic wedgie how
about a purple nurple where made my
famous indian
arm burn ow oh how about i just grab
your own hand
why are you hitting yourself why are you
hating yourself ow want me to stop you
better say it
you better say it
a christmas sketch show jerk farcus
stupid bully you know setting aside the
ralphie probably wrote a rant about his
gun
the c plus is probably because he
misspelled christmas
christmas well there you go yeah
them's a christmas story for you
uh final thoughts about it before we go
into uh
any any outtakes or uh anything else
that's that's all there is to say it's
it's i couldn't believe it there i was
discussing a christmas story
it was the worst year of my life it was
it was the best commentaries we'd ever
done
uh okay well thank you guys for watching
um subscribe if you haven't subscribed
yet
like if you haven't liked yet uh we got
some new videos uh
on the phantom entertainment thing uh
sasha pearl raver an old fave did a
three-part series on how
uh movies are made specifically big
blockbuster marvel movies you know
the pre-production production
post-production so check those out we
posted those over the weekend which is
nice
um and you're
doing a show joe would you like to tell
the people about it oh yeah i am
uh we're uh so uh fandom
uh just published our first uh rpg book
uh cortex
which i have here uh it's a very pretty
uh book and a very cool system and we're
launching a show to support it which
starts on thursday it'll be
um a live play show along the lines of
like
critical role or uh uh
some of the stuff i used to do uh he
left dead and pencils and parsecs and
stuff like that
um it's a great cast of vanessa gritten
from sju
elisa pearl and some really cool uh
folks from fandom
are going to be doing this we'll be
doing like probably different stories
every month and stuff like that because
the cool thing about cortex is that it
um it's really sort of like a foundation
or like a box of legos so you can be
like what
what kind of thing do i want to do uh so
the first one we're
doing is a setting called hammerheads
and it's uh it's basically like
uh disaster movie stuff so think like
san andreas in 2012 and armageddon uh
it's gonna be super super fun
uh i'm playing um like a
20 like a fox news pundit
that uh uh thinks that the united states
shouldn't be funding
this control uh emergency response team
and just wants to end it
uh so that's gonna be fun uh and uh that
launches
uh thursday three and we've got a link
in the description uh if you've never
watched something like this before it's
basically like an improvised like audio
drama
super fun all right all right well check
that out it's called
roll and keep i'm told so roll and keep
uh roll them if you got them keep them
if you have them
um thursday is 3pm like joe said all
right do you remember
gurpsjo from the 90s that was also
a like platform on which you could build
your own role-playing games it's like
it's like a cool cool idea to bring that
back i like it yeah it's sweet
um we have outtakes let's see what they
were
hey and making up outlandish threats to
justify owning a gun
and what the nra calls a feel-good
holiday classic for the whole family
you can still smack a kid around for
laughs
and openly laugh at asian immigrants
accents while they try to accommodate
your family
they're different than we are merry
christmas
stories they were like going above and
beyond to give them
uh uh christmas after theirs was ruined
and they're like
they sound funny they don't say family
sucks
but fits with the rest of the movie of a
family who kind of sucks
um it definitely feels like uh
re-watching it i felt like this
simpsons in particular drew some some
key
inspiration from this family and like
the specific kind of ways that they suck
it's interesting especially when you
were pointing out the like
moms barely hanging on by a thread like
she's got a lot of like marge simpson
frazzled barely holding it together mom
energy
plus they can both get it
all right moving on
get your gun wreck it ralphie all i want
for christmas
is shoot bb king it keeps groaning and
groaning and groaning
randy raising dope worth
it working the pole damn
imminent death of a salesman father
knows fast
american dad this means
[Music]
and something coyote okay boomer
the movie a very white christmas
the blunder year
ta-da all right uh good times what did
y'all have to say about um adam halbert
writes
so does it confirm the movie is about
epic voice guys childhood
i guess if they're if it was a crossover
with
scott farkas oh right yeah perhaps yeah
maybe he was just from the same
neighborhood and was also
bullied by scott farkas maybe our maybe
our new canon can be
that epic voice guy suspects that um uh
what's the narrator in a christmas
story's name again
bravely no the the actual gene shepard
yeah maybe
maybe uh uh epic voice guys suspects
that gene shepard is actually his father
oh interesting yeah i can see that
confirmed both have epic voices
i i think scott farkas is just a
dimension hopping
like he's a multiverse capable bully
whenever whenever nerds need noogies or
whatever he
he appears right stuffs you into a
locker
um it's terrifying uh all right sg
rapness writes what other movies should
be played 24 hours for reasons
that's interesting like holiday movies
are just
movies just generally i mean i i think
it's a gimme but independence day on
july
4th 24 hours like oh yeah there you go
that makes sense
i think that's another one where you can
be like oh let me just watch this five
minutes before i walk out the door i
know
i feel like we all sort of agree planes
trains is the ultimate
thanksgiving movie so that would be
another one that all day thanksgiving
day you should just stay with the planes
trains and automobiles
uh halloween you gotta go um
uh uh for a variety of reasons the
garfield halloween special okay
it's only 10 minutes long and so you get
that many more viewings in a 24-hour
field halloween special was a full half
hour was it not yeah
i believe there's a full half hour of
action there
well i would do i would replace they end
up on like an island or something anyway
there's pirate goats
yeah there's papa pyrikos the one thing
i'm not there's a scary cat sorry i
really like that special
clearly damn i gotta revisit that one
uh i think i would like to replace a
christmas story
uh on the 24 hour loop but this is
recency bias because i saw it last week
but let's replace it with go
which also takes place on christmas and
and has like you know it's like four
vignettes they kind of intersect you can
technically a christmas movie christmas
movie you can just watch the one
where like jay moore is the gay
undercover cop that
gets in too deep with william fichner
and then uh and then leave
when um uh katie holmes uh uh
almost ods or whatever you know do you
think you add the narrator into
yeah i was gonna say i was about to buy
ecstasy from timothy oliphant
the rave where we got into the biggest
pickle
yes i want the ralphie cut of go 24
hours
got very sick off of the buffet shrimp
you put the hat on timothy oliphant
six packs abs i swear to god he had
six-pack abs
would want to hang out with us for a
whole weekend i guess here he was
is hanging out with those other dudes i
don't know dig seems like he's from a
cooler friend
group but somehow he ended up in the
breckenmire bunch but i'm not sure i'd
buy that
what do you want for christmas katie
holmes uh
how about a nice tracy lord cd
[Laughter]
bravo you guys all right we can't top
that let's uh let's tease him with next
week
um which is also a movie that's sort of
in its own time and place out of time if
you will
um so yeah there's your clue
uh i hope you enjoyed a christmas story
and on australia commentaries because we
will be back with more
next week thanks guys and thanks
everyone for watching merry christmas
[Music]
you